thank you very much Mr chairman ladies
and gentlemen we are awaiting a very
firm reaction of the world to today's
Russian Terror response of our partners
response of our friends not just
observers but uh reaction from all those
who really recognize the UN Charter
we're doing everything possible Ukraine
represented a peace from you the world
heard it the 10 items in a order to make
empower the Church of U.N and violated
by Russian guarantee security for
Ukraine Europe and all the peoples of
this plan suffering from the
consequences of the Russian aggression
in response to our peace formula Russia
is following the items of their formula
of Terror the very next day after my
presentation of the Ukrainian peace
formula at g19 Summit in Indonesia we
received 10 M Russian missiles for every
item of the peace formula the impact
continued even further we liberated
Harrison and as soon as the Russian army
fled from there they started
methodically
devastating the city every day we have
an impact this night another missile
impact in the Parisa region it was a
hospital this time the maternity worth
the Russian terrorists took a life over
child it was two days um
um
old when
killed by the Russian missile we have
that we have scores of um
today we have a residential house hit 35
people suffered for that so today is
just one day but we have received 17
missiles that's the Russian formula of
Terror this is all against our energy
infrastructure there is a hit also with
the residential house damage the
hospital schools transport residential
districts all suffered the Russian
Terror that to a complete back out not
just in Ukraine but also in neighboring
Moldova but the Forum ceased to be
supplied but what shouldn't sees is
understanding what Russia wants to
achieve with such impact energy Turner
this is weaponizing of the mass
destruction
means when we have the temperature below
zero and scores of millions of people
stay without energy supplies without
heating without water this is an obvious
crime against humanity ladies and
gentlemen in your midst you have
representatives of the state that does
not offer anything to the world but
Terror of the stabilization that is
information
any Russian formula
um can offer nothing but this when the
instigator of this war when the party
responsible for this terror is blocking
any attempt on behalf of the Council of
Security Council to execute its mandate
it's nonsense that the leader right is
secured for the
um
party that wages this war this criminal
War we have to drive the world out of
this dead event this is absolutely
possible we cannot be hostage one
international terrorist Russia is doing
everything to make an energy generator a
more powerful tool than the UN Charter
but we can bring the real sense back to
all the things and first of all the um
Charter we need your decisions thank you
very much for the opportunity for your
attention glory be to Ukraine